。
同学们好啊，咱们上课。
今天呢讲一节计划外的内容。
为什么呢？
是因为我最近发现一个问题。
一个严重的问题。
就是咱们这个课呀。
已经上了一年了。
很多同学从一开始就听课啊，听到现在也一年了。
竟然一个字儿都还没写呢。
啥情况啊，你们。
然后我就很生气啊。
因为我强调过呀。
编剧这个东西你要写，你要练呀。
我不是还说过吗？你怎么也得有个50万字的磨合期吧，对不对？
你得写你得练才能发现问题，才能更深刻的理解咱们的课程，才能提高自己，对不对？
然后我也简单仿听了一下，就是这类同学他是咋想。
我发现分两类。
一类呢。
就是。
非常的不自信。
就说老师我还没准备好，我基础太差。
我想把您的课都听完了，再好好巩固巩固，我再开始写。我现在真的是我怕写出来丢脸，贻笑大方，不好意思。
这是第一种。
就是过于不自信了。
第二种呢。
就相反过于自信了。
我问他你咋还没写呢？他说老师你可能不了解情况。我有一个故事啊，能震惊世界。
等我酝酿好了，我只要一写哎。
别说拿奥斯卡或者金棕榈什么的吧，至少他必须得给我商业化。
我这个故事上来就得挣大钱，300万起跳。
是吧。
就分这两种同学，一种十分不自信，一种十分自信。
同学们都不可取啊。
赶紧给我写。
赶紧给我练。
因为你光说不练是不行的，同学们光听课没有用。
你还是得自己写自己练。
这就像啥，你知道吗？像。
像学车，比如说对吧？我是你们的驾校教练。
我可以教会你们。
所有的东西。
基本上所有的规则和所有的技巧，我其实都跟你们说说了说过。
但是你自己不上路练。
肯定是不行的。
你还是得上路呀。
对吧哪怕上来先慢点，怂点儿。
溜边先开对不对？或者找个没人的地方开，你不自信，你就找个没人的地方开嘛，你自己写了，你你自己看嘛，对不对？
太自信了也不行啊，你撞了怎么办？你把别人你撞了，你自己还好说，你把别人撞了咋整？
对吧这两类同学都不行啊，就好像他妈学车，我带你们上路。第一类就哎呀，我不敢我不敢上路，我我我我害怕。
第二类呢就是过来一探头。
这是F1吗？
不是F1赛场啊。
不是F一赛场，我可不开啊，我学车是为了开F一的对吧？我为了。
那个那个上那个F1赛道的这个普通的马路我不开。
哎呀，这两种情况都不行啊。
必须得练。
必须得写。
但是这个情况既然普遍存在啊。
那也不能怪全怪同学们。
怪我。
对吧。
我是个老师呀。
我得帮大家解决这个问题。
其实像这两种情况啊。
都是比较典型的拖延症。
灰眼那其实就是这种情况。
拖延症一般不是懒。
或者不是常规意义上你们认为的懒是给懒找借口。
一般的借口就是我还没准备好。
对吧我一旦一旦到哪个时间点，我开我就开始。
我就开始干。
这就是标准的拓延长。
那既然普遍存在，咱们就来解决一下这个问题啊。
解决这个问题，那你首先就得知道这个问题的原理，知道拖延症的原理。
会员这的原理其实特别简单，就是你不愿走出自己的舒适区。
就是你缩在自己的舒适区里了。
咱们知道这个这个舒适区啊，这个概念啊，心理学上说。
人类对外部世界的认知啊分三个区，对吧？
舒适区。
然后学习区。
然后。
恐慌区吧是叫对吧？
就分这三个区。
然后呢，我们大部分人啊。
大部分人的大部分时候是喜欢。
缩在自己的舒适区里的，为啥特舒适呀？
舒适，所以你会有安全感。你在舒适区里呆着呢很安全。
但学习这件事情呢。
他就肯定在学习区里了，要不这个这一层也不会叫学习区嘛，与学习有关的事情啊。
都在学习区里。
比如说啊。
看书。
写作。
都在自己的学习区里。
那恐慌区是啥呢？恐慌区就是你去了之后啊。
比学习区还不适应，就到恐慌的程度了。
害怕。
你知道吗？
比如说。
随便举个例子啊，比如说当众演讲。
对于大多数人来说。
就是个恐慌区。
那么我们说这三个区它就是固定的吗？当然不是。
当然不是。
所以学习的意义就在这里。学你如果坚持学习，每天能够勇敢的走进学习区。
你的舒适区就会越来越大。因为有一部分学习区会变成你的舒适区。时间长了以后啊。
然后呢，由于你学习区的外延不断的扩大，会导致你的恐慌区也越来越小。
举例子来说啊，就说我们这个学习这个读和写。
读书和写作。
他是在学习区的。
对吧比如说我们小时候。
刚开始学读书的时候，同学们。
你会读书吗？
你不会。
你只会念书。
同学们回忆一下，我们上小学一年级的时候。
每次读课文，老师要求我们朗读。
为什么？
是因为读书还没有进入你的舒适区。
你只能把它念出来，然后通过听觉去吸收。
但是到小学二三年级的时候呢，老师就开始让你默睹。
因为你通过朗读时不断的练习，不断的学习，你把念书纳入舒适区了。
把念书纳入书室去了。
然后小学的时候写作文。
一年级写日记随便写，不要求字数。二三年级呢开始要求个什么100字200字，对吧？然后上初中开始什么300字、500字。
对吧上高中什么800字1000字。
慢慢的把写作也从你的学习区纳入舒适区了。同学们，你回忆一下呀，你回忆一下，你们20岁以前你在学校的时候。
念书和写作。
会让你这么难受吗？
你那时候天天念书，天天看书，天天写写作，天天写字。
但是呢对于我们大多数人来说啊。
从学校出来以后。
毕业了以后。
就把你之前拓展的这些学习区啊。
又都给退出去了。
你又通过长时间的归缩。
8、念书和写作。
环到。
学习区里了。
不舒适了。
你看你现在我问同学们，假设你现在是1个25岁以上的人，我问你。
你现在还能完整的看完一本书吗？
恐怕早就不能了。
或者也很多年没有看过。
因为你看书你已经不舒适了。
你看着不得劲儿了。
你看着犯困了。
同理。
你现在。
写作的时候。
你也觉得不舒适啦。
想当年。
高中的时候啊写作文。
每次语文考试不都得写吗？
甚至英文考试也得写呀。
你写的好吗？
你写的并不好，但你不照样写吗？硬着头皮在写吗？
对不对？
所以啊。
本质上其实没有什么拖延件儿。同学们。
就是因为现在你在舒适区里呆着。
没人治你。
我跟你说啊。
你再懒再拖延。
老虎来了，你拔腿就好。
就是啊。
因为你要逃命呀。
所以说大部分人啊在长大了以后啊，在舒适区里呆着，这当然不怪大家啊，因为在舒适区里呆着是人的本能。
人本身就是这么设计出来的。
至于。
有些杠精同学就要说，那人本身就是这么设计出来的那我就这样活着呗。
但问题是人本身设计的时候啊。
寿命是很短的。
人本身设计的时候，远古的时候人只能活30岁呀。
对不对？你如果人只能活30岁，那你在舒适区里待一生其实也是可以的。
反正大家人与人之间也没有什么差别。
但是现在人。
人类社会的发展，科技的发展本身就是个逆天改命的过程嘛，我们都他妈撑到七八十岁了，能活七八十岁了。所以他很多事情就已经。
跟天性相违背了。
天性要求你舒适，要求你懒惰，但是社会要求你学习，要求你恐慌呀。
我刚才说来恐慌区，比如说当众演讲就是恐慌区。
对于大多数人来说就是。
对于我来说啊。
以前也是恐慌区。
你当众演讲，你怎么可能不紧张，怎么可能不头晕，怎么可能不嘚瑟呢？
怎么可能不低血糖，两眼一滑想晕倒呢？
不可能的，当众演讲肯定恐慌。
但是。
你就不当做演讲了吗？
你就不挑战这件事情了吗？
就是通过不断的练习，把这件事情把当当中演讲，比如说杨本在这儿纳入进你的学习区里。
现在演讲。
面对，比如说8000人一个大场子演讲就在我的学习区里。
我不可能很舒适，我也得精心的准备，反复的练习，甚至夜不能寐。
很紧张嘛，对吧？
但是绝不至于恐慌。
撅在那里是不太会的对吧？所以说你看这就是我说学习的意义。
当然了，特别牛逼的那种人，世界上可能也有那种人，就学习特别牛逼，舒适区扩得越来越大。
把当做演讲都纳入自己的舒适区里了，张嘴就来对吧？面对几千人张嘴就来叨叨叨叨叨叨几个小时。
可能也有这种人啊。
可能也有这种人。
我觉得应该有。
应该有应该有。
这个题外话啊，咱们就说咱们的学习来，你现在。
躺在自己的舒适区里。
这件事情。
咱咋解决？
不解决肯定不行啊。
不解决肯定不行。
所以咱们这节课呀。
就来解决这个问题。
咱们在编剧学习这条路上。
大家勇敢的走出自己的舒适区。
我们写起来。
咱们。
上路。
咱们科目三好不好？
这节课啊咱们就上科目三。
科目3。
必须得上路了。
科目三啥意思呢？
就是大家要。
上车了要自己写了。
那肯定就不舒适了。
对吧。
肯定就不舒适了。
但是。
老师的意义是什么呢？
老师的意义。
就是尽可能的。
让学习。
变得舒适。
这也是为什么好的课程你能听进去的原因。
明明是在讲知识，但是呢。
你似乎感受到了一些舒适对吧？他也不可能完全舒适啊，完全舒适，那有点扯淡了。
那说明你可能没听知识，光听扯淡了是吧？
就好的课程呀。
是力求把。
学习。
变得相对舒适，我们只能这么说。
所以这节课咱们是科目三。
肯定是要你进入学习区的。
但是咱们也尽量。
我先让你舒适一会儿。
先给大家讲几个案例。
也就是你们比较喜欢听的拉片。
讲几个案例，这节课呢我给大家找了。
几个片子。
我们用这几个片子为模型。
进行一组命题作文的练习，好吧。
第一个片子。
绿野仙踪我就不写全了啊。绿野仙踪。
1939年。
应该是美国迪斯尼出的吧。
反正是39年啊，美国的。
一个电影叫绿野仙踪。
大家可以先看一下，然后呢。
再继续听这节课的内容啊。
你们可以暂停先去找那个片子看一下。
这个片子是39年的。
可以说是公路片的开山鼻祖吧。
很标杆性的一个片子啊。
之所以讲这个片子呢，是因为这个片子年头够久，当时呢还处于一个雏形状态。雏形状态呢它就干净了。
他就结构。
一目了然。
我们用几句话来说清楚这个故事的内容。
绿野仙踪。
的主角叫陶乐斯，对吧？
陶乐斯呢。
生活在。
一个农场里，对吧？跟他叔叔和他婶儿生活在一个农场里。
呃，没有爸爸妈妈生活在农场里。
然后因为这个这个他这个小狗啊在外面惹事，惹了这个镇上的这个一个有权有势的一个恶毒的。
女性吧，恶毒的妇女。
然后这个恶毒的妇女呢就来。
要毁灭人道毁灭这个这个小狗对吧？就是一。
抓狗队的。
要把这个小狗抓走，然后陶乐斯呢很害怕。
好，很害怕就是。
就想逃离这个。
农场想离家出走。
离家出走呢。
好死不死，赶上了这个龙卷风啊，我们知道美国啊龙卷风挺多的，因为它这个大陆啊南北通透，一马平川。
很容易刮大风。
然后就是遭遇了龙卷风。
美国因为经常遭遇龙卷风呢，所以他们每一家每户有地下室，就是专门躲风用的。
其他人呢都躲进地下室了，他因为离家出走，在外面逛悠，没有没有及时躲起来。
就被龙卷风给。
吹走。
吹到哪儿去了呢？
吹到了一个。
奇幻的世界里。
吹到了一个奇幻的世界里。
然后故事。
基本上是从这里开始展开的。
在这个奇幻的世界里，陶乐斯。
我们说他的。
欲望。
只回家。
对吧他的欲望是回家。
然后他得到一个什么线索呢？就是人家告诉他，在路的尽头，在某个地方有个大法师。
有个大法师。
这个大法师呢可以帮助你回家。
然后呢，他就一路去寻找这个大法师。
我们说基本上就是这么一个故事脉络。
详细说的话，那就是陶乐斯。
首先来到的是。
那个国家叫什么，我忘了啊。
叫小人国吧。
好吧，就全小儿国。
他降落在小儿国，然后嘞。
嗯，降落的时候压死了一个。
女巫。
就意外搞死了一个女巫。
然后降落在这个小儿国，然后这个女巫呢有个亲姐们儿。
有个姐妹儿，然后呢就是我们的对手对手女巫。
就要找陶乐斯报仇。
所以他形成了一个反派力量。
然后陶乐斯要回家，就要去找一个叫。
呃，欧Z国的一个大法师，对吧？
找这个大法师呢有有一个路径，就是一条黄砖路。
很简单很干净的一个路径，叫黄砖路，对吧？一条黄路黄砖路。然后他的对手呢就是这个女巫这个反派。
然后上路之后。
上路之后，他依次遇到了三个伙伴，这个熟悉绿野仙踪的同学都都都知道啊。第一个嘛稻草人是吧？稻草人。
然后稻草人。
听说他要去找大法师，决定跟他一块儿走，为啥呢？
稻草人说，我恩没有脑。
对吧我是个草包呀，我没有大脑。
他去找。
办法师去找找大脑，对吧？
然后嘞。
遇到的第二个伙伴是一个铁皮人是吧？一个铁皮人，铁皮人呢？
说我那我也去，我想找一颗心，对吧？我想找一颗心。然后呢，第三个伙伴呢是狮子，对吧？
狮子好啊。
呃，狮子这个狮子是个怂狮子，胆小的狮子，对吧？所以他是想。
去找勇气。
对吧找勇气。
就是遇到了这么三个伙伴。
然后带着这个三个伙伴，那肯定一路上。
一路上肯定需要有各种阻碍，对吧？我们说阻碍阻力分三种嘛，环境的阻碍，他们肯定也有环境的阻碍呀什么。
这个毒苹果呀，这个这个啥环境这个又渴又累呀，这种环境上的阻碍。因为凡是这个路程那必然遥远而坚险啊，然后对手的阻碍就是那个那个。
这个坏女巫包括坏坏女巫，还有马仔呢飞猴飞天猴子，对吧？
不是磕这恶啊磕这恶是飞天别问飞天小龙霸了啊，反正就飞飞天猴子。
也经常来捣乱对手。
然后这个这个这个自己也有阻碍呀，这几个人都都都挺无能的对吧？
然后呢呃在故事终点的位置是找到了大法师，对吧？我们说虚假的胜利，先找到大法师，但是呢大法师不肯帮他们，因为他找到大法师，他是为了回家。然后呢，他们三个也各自有各自的目标。我们说这是个主角群，主角群需要有同样一个行动员。
对吧。
主角群。
找到了大法师，但是大法师不不帮他们。
没有帮他们实现愿望。
提出了一个新的条件。我们说这这里是故事终点嘛，对吧？
故事是终点的时候，我们说有时候呃故事终点。
一般是伪胜利或者伪失败，对吧？在这里是一个伪胜利，就是找到了大法师。但是大法师呢没有。
没有实现他们的。
愿望，而是重新跟他们谈了个条件。我们说这叫加大赌注。
大瓦师跟他们谈了一个什么条件呢？
说。
你们把这个女巫的那个扫帚调整。
给我弄来。
弄来之后，我就门就帮你就提了一个很。
很具象的条件。
他们一路奔，就是在躲这个人啊，因为这个人很凶的嘛，要搞死他们嘛，对吧？
然后要要要要搞死他。
呃，但是这时候他们需要去主动去找他了。
要干他，所以呢这三个人调整方向去找这个女巫。
就又往女巫的方向走，然后经过。
呃，这个这个过关斩将。
把女巫消灭，拿到了。
约定的条件达成了约定的条条件，拿到了那个扫帚，然后回来找这个大法师，结果发现这个大法师呢。
狗屁不会，假的，根本不是个法师，就是个凡人，对吧？就是个凡人，是个大忽悠。
然后这个。
就回不了家了。
回不了家了，但是这个大忽悠呢说，哎呀，你跟这个稻草人说，你找什么大脑呀，你不就是想要智慧吗？你看你在这一路上。
你用你的智慧解决了很多问题啊，其实你有智慧呀，然后跟这个铁皮人说，你要什么心啊，你其实不就想关心别人吗？要心不就是为了善良。
你本来就很善良呀，你不善良的话，你会保护陶乐斯吗？对不对？然后又跟这个狮子说，你不要这个勇气，你就是个勇敢的人呀。你看你在与女巫的战斗中。
你表现的多勇敢啊，你现在已经有勇气了。
然后呢，至于那个陶乐斯想回家这件事情，他当然努力了一下，做了一下尝试就是。
就用热气球吧。
他用热气球说，哎，我们用热气球回家了，结果热气球没成功。
最后呢发现一个问题。
就是。
陶勒斯在。
第一次降临到小人国的时候，不是压死了一个女巫吗？
压死了一个女巫，这个女巫有一个关键道具叫。
红宝石鞋。
就有一双鞋。
然后他就他他就得到了这双鞋穿上了，当时就得到这个道具了。
然后也就是因为这双鞋，所以反派女巫一直跟着他想夺回这双鞋，因为这双鞋是有魔力的，很厉害。
然后在这里重新解读这双鞋，重新解读我们的祈实道具，发现这双鞋是可以带他回家的。
跺几下脚就可以了。
然后嘞就用鞋。
回家了。
就用这双鞋回家了。那很明显，这双鞋就是周星驰的如来神掌。
周星驰的如来神掌，或者是苏乞儿的降龙十八掌。
就是重新解读道具。
已达到目的回家。
打到我们。
为了讲，当然这是一个童话故事，它是一个奇幻世界。
讲述的是一个农场女孩陶乐斯跟叔叔婶婶生活在一起。因为。
没有爸爸妈妈，对吧？然后呢，对现实生活对现状生活不满。
他觉得。
大家都对我不好，不开心，他甚至唱出了那一首。
团世名曲over the rainbow对吧？他说他要去彩虹以外的地方去看一看，对吧？因为这个小小的农场束缚我了，哎呀，我的人生被束缚了，跟我们很多同学一样嘛，对吧？我的人生被束缚了，我要出去看一看，他呢想的更远，他说要到over the rainbow的地方去看一看。
然后呢，哎你不是想over the rainbow吗？龙卷风来了，把它刮到了一个。
偶尔的人宝的地方。
压死了一个。
女巫。
踏上第二步，我们说这叫痛打看门狗啊，踏上第二幕，要痛打看门狗。看门狗就是他压死那个女巫进到第二幕，然后遭遇伙伴。
呃，获得道具也在第二幕，然后伙伴。
然后对手。
重点。
重新谈条件，然后再达成。
然后发现。
这个欧德法师帮不了他。
然后绕过动作实现欲望，欲望是回家，动作是找法师，法师帮不了他。
自己帮自己。
你说你看。
这就是。
绿野仙踪。
我们说我们为什么先讲这个片子呢？
因为这个片子啊。
很干净。
他很老啊，那时候没有什么花活。
一切都很规整。
像方程式一样，你们不觉得这个片子就像一个。
模板吗？
多一个人也不多。
对吧多一场戏也没有，就是很规整。
规整。
但是他却奠定了往后。
很多很多这个类型片子的。
基本结构。
它规整啊有两个原因，一个是因为他老倚老卖老嘛，他就规可可以规整。
第二个原因呢，是因为它是个寓言故事。
它是个童话故事嘛。
这是个寓言故事，因为这个陶乐斯最后回到家之后，发现一切是一场梦。
一切是一场梦。
并没有去什么。
Somewhere over the rainbow.
他只是做了一场梦，一场可怕的梦。
我们说这就是绿野仙踪。
我们再来看一个片子。
这个片子呢我们说是一个老的片子。
预演的片子。
我们再来看一个。
写实的片子。
真人的片子。
比较新的片子。
菊次郎的夏天。
我们说菊次郎的夏天也是一个公路片，对吧？
主角是菊次拉河。
正南。
郑男是那个小朋友呀。
那个那个那个那个憨憨的那个小朋友。
然后。
我们说假设男主角是郑南，因为起始的目标是正南的啊，起始目标是正南的。就是说这个故事是由正南挑起的。
其实目标是正难的。
虽然片子叫菊次郎的夏天，这个我们待会儿再说。我们说从正南的角度。
他的欲望是什么？我们就按照陶螺斯的结构啊来看，橘色啊夏天蒸南的目标是什么？
找他妈。
然后。
正男的现状是什么呢？
郑楠是个孤儿。
嗯，没有没有爸爸，也没有妈妈。
跟外婆生活在一起跟外婆生活在一起，然后呢放暑假了。
放暑假了之后呢嗯。
现状是什么呢？我们说一般啊现状不可接受嘛。
陶勒斯也觉得现状不可接受呀，觉得家里人都不理解他，对吧？觉得哎呀在家里很憋屈，那郑男也是呀。
他外婆虽然对他不错，但是呢。
你毕竟孤独呀，所以他的现状也不可接受。
放暑假。
没事儿干，本来就没事干。然后嘞。
先是去踢足球，就他最喜欢踢足球，结果发现暑假呢足球兴趣班也不上不上课。那个教练跟他说的嘛，说暑假了呃这个这个足球班也关了，你回家了，然后他回家。
然后他又去找他最好的一个朋友。
就是放学跟他放一块走的那个小男孩去人家里喊，喊了半天，发现人家的爸爸妈妈带着这个小男孩一家几口开上一辆旅行车过暑假去了，去旅行去了，又把他给扔下了。
人家跟他说再见，那个镜头。
没有根去那个小男孩家里，就拍正男在楼下喊人家下来玩，然后上去看人家怎么回事，然后又跟人家一块下来，人家一家人拿着行李上人辆车开走，跟他说再见。
现状不可接受，孤独没事干，对吧？完全没事干。然后呢，激励是什么呢？他一个人在家的时候翻东西，发现了他妈的地址和照片。
因为他们。
不怎么记得他妈妈。
更不可能知道他妈在哪。所以你看这个就是激利事件。
这个就是纪率事件，他发现他妈的东西了。
就是。
呃，所以。
现状。
不可接受，然后踏上找妈的旅程，对吧？找妈的旅程第一件事情先揣了点钱，收拾了点行李上路，对吧？
上路第一件事情是什么呢？
被打劫被抢被抢。
被几个不良少年给抢了。
然后嘞，这时候谁出现了呢？菊次郎菊次郎就是北野舞。
我们的凶悍的大叔对吧？凶悍的大叔出现了，把被抢的这几个小男孩给扁了一顿，还把被抢的这几个不良少年的进给抢了。因为他很凶悍嘛，这是什么？
对应这里。
呃，看门狗。
看门狗呀。
看看第二幕。
痛展看门狗。
然后呢，对应稻草人、铁皮人狮子，这里不就是我们的菊次郎吗？
菊次郎帮助他打了看门狗，然后菊次郎加入到。
队伍里面加入到我们的郑南的队伍里面。当然了，菊次郎在这里是被迫的，也不叫完全被迫啊，是因为他有个老婆，他老婆我们说被一个他他的老婆，他在戏里面啊在剧里面称之为老婆啊就是。
呃，跟他说你。
你你你这小孩多可怜，你带他去那个路又那么远，去那么远的地方，你带他去嘛，你保护他，你带他去找他妈妈。
然后呢，这个女人因为也认识菊次郎的外婆，还跑去那个。
外婆家跟外婆说，那个那个我老公呃。
带带带带张南出去玩几天，去海边玩几天，你就放心工作吧。因为外婆也确实忙也顾不过来，再加上可能。
人家确实也是有亲属关系，所以也比较放心啊也比较放心。
所以在这个女人的支配下。
菊次郎加入了。
正南找妈妈的旅程，菊次郎相当于。
呃，稻草儿、铁皮人和狮子的合体。
然后呢，这是伙伴。
然后一路我们说因为是个现实主义的片子，可能就不能打女巫了。
对吧一路呀就要与现实做斗争。比如说上来他们俩先去堵自行车。
就是去赌博吧。
赌博呃赢了点钱，然后后来又把钱给输光了，得意忘形把钱给输光。然后呢，那钱是现实主义题材啊，你记得啊现实主义题材。
阻碍里面一般少不了钱，就是呢没钱对吧？没有钱，然后呢，没有钱。那在这个漫长的路程当中，那显然就坐不成车，要去蹭车，对吧？要装可怜，要什么甚至要在路上放钉子，扎人家车胎，反正要做各种各样的事情去想办法。
偷点东西呀，赖点账啊，或者是有时候北野武因为是一个流氓出身，还要就有时候用武力去解决一些问题呀。
然后甚至他们在路上。
郑南还遭遇了什么呢？他们在没有钱的时候呢，就是郑南还被一个变态大叔。
一个色情狂的大叔就是就是那种。
专门搞小男孩的那种。
还被还被那样一个人给欺负了。
然后郑南晚上做噩梦都是那件事情，对吧？
嗯。
我们说遭遇各种各样的。
遭遇各种各样的事情，其中还遇到。
呃，好人也有好人，对吧？好心的情侣，还有一个好，他们叫好心叔叔。
一个好心人叔好人叔叔。
还遇到一个好人叔叔也带了他们一段，终于到达目的地。
终点啊，我们说在终点。
找到了。
妈妈的住所找到了妈妈的住所。
那终点这里找到了大法师，找到了妈妈。
结果发现妈妈什么呢？因为找到，因为我们说凡是找妈妈，其实都是为了找爱嘛，对不对？
都是为了找爱，是因为这难孤独嘛，是为找爱，但是这里找到了妈妈，找不到爱。
为啥呢？
他本来他外婆跟他讲，因为他外婆呢肯定是妈妈的亲妈呀。
按道理应该知道自己的女儿在哪。
对吧。
外婆跟他讲，你妈妈在外地打工呢，你爸爸去世以后，你妈妈就去外地打工了。
他呢在那努力工作，挣钱养着你，所以你好好读书，乖乖的就可以了。这是他外婆跟他。
说法。
去到那儿之后呢，发现。
妈妈住着一个豪宅。
嫁了一个有钱的老公，又生了一个比她小不了多少，小一点点的。
过着幸福的生活。
也就是说。
妈妈不可能。
就不可能爱他了。
妈妈知道你在哪儿，也从来没来看过你，对吧？妈妈不爱你了。
这就是终点。
这就是我们的重点。
当然了，菊次郎会去。
会去弥补这件事情。徐次郎跟郑南说。
找错了，我帮你刚才问了，那不是你吗？
你妈又搬家了，咱们还得接着找啊。
对吧咱们还得接着找吧。
咱们下回再找，咱们明年暑假。
再来找。
当然把这事儿给折去折过去了。但是我们从为观众从观众的角度或者其实正男这个小男孩虽然看起来傻傻的。
因为菊次郎跟他说，那不是你妈骂之后，我说完之后这男孩子哭了嘛。
他怎么可能不知道呢？
对吧。
还有照片的呀。
还有照片呢。
所以说找到了妈妈，但没有找到爱。
然后在这里呢。
我们说。
在终点过后。
除了重新谈条件，加大赌注以外，还有一个还有一种。
常规的做法叫调整目标。
在调整目标。
在这里我们就换目标了。
菊次郎和郑男就换目标了，菊次郎给他换的。从中点过后，菊次郎做了一件什么事情呢？菊次郎正好看到有一。
有两个骑哈雷摩托车的那种。
骑着哈雷穿着皮坎肩那种看起来很凶悍的那种。
机车党吧。
汽车党的那个那个。
车车把上挂着一个。
小玩具挂着一个小天使。
然后呢，菊次郎因为是个虎逼啊。
对吧他是一个很很很凶恶的一个大叔，然后就去把那两个机车党给抢了。那那俩机车党反而挺温柔的。
呃，跟外形不符。
把那俩机车党的小天使给抢了。
然后回来带给他说哎。
那个我刚才问那个女人了，你妈妈搬走了。
嗯。
呃，不住在这儿了。所以呢我们可能明年暑假要继续找你妈，但是你妈走的时候呢，给你留下一个。
留下一个信物。
是一个小天使。
是一个小天使铃铛。
一个小天使形状的铃铛。
你摇这个铃铛呢？
你妈妈就知道呃，你想他了。
他就会派一个天使来保护你。
编造了这个谎言给郑南。
然后郑南在后半段。
那就是。
我们说前半段找妈妈。
后半段目标调整变成了。
小天使。
然后他就。
不断的。
摇起这个铃铛。
然后我们在前半段路程中遇到过的，包括菊次郎也好，也就北业务也好。
包括那一对骑机车的。
机车党一个一个肥仔，一个光头。
然后还有那个好人叔叔。
这几个人。
轮流。
扮演。
开始。
做出了很多荒诞的。
搞笑的场景。
轮流。
夸张的表演。
充当正南的天使。
然后郑南也在。
整个故事中。
第一次笑了。
我们说郑南这个小男孩啊，我们暂时。
暂时把它确定为男主角的话。
其实长得不咋地呀，长得挺丑的，你知道吧？长得挺憨的。一般这种戏我给你找一个漂亮男孩啊。
但是因为是北野舞的作品，咱肯定不按查理出牌呀。
这是小男孩第一次笑了，也就是说。
举次郎也好。
一对鸡血党也好，还有那个偷玉米的时候认识的好人叔叔也好，好人叔叔是偷玉米的时候认识碰到的又。
在那偷人家的玉米，小偷，你知道吗？
但是都展现出了。
天使的一面。
或者说。
都变成了天使。
甚至。
我们的正南呢？
他也有有一个新书包。
他在路上，他本来背着自己上学的书包上路的，他后来回来的时候呢，买了一个新书包。
别5，也就是菊次郎给他买了一个新书包。
那个书包上。
也有一对儿。
白色的小翅吗。
也就是说。
后半段找天使。
前半段找母爱，找妈妈没找到。
咱妈妈的爱。
可以被什么给替代呢？
那就是天使的爱。
天使在哪里呢？
他们都是天使。
菊次郎是天使。
机车党是天使。
偷玉米的好人叔叔。
也是天使。
甚至正难你自己。
你也可以是天使。
所以最后变成了寻找天使。
和成为天使。
因为我们正南啊。
他不光得到了这些天使的帮助。
为什么说他自己也成为天使了呢？
是因为。
他获得了这些爱，获得了这些开心。
甚至让我们的菊次郎，我们说菊次郎为什么要帮助这么难呢？其实开篇的时候讲过那个支配他的女人讲过。
那个女人跟他说。
你不觉得这小孩可怜吗？
妈妈不要他了。
你妈不也不要你了吗？
因为菊次郎也没有妈妈呀，或者说他妈妈也抛弃他了。
所以在故事。
后半段的时候，菊次郎。
去了一家敬老院。
远远的。
看了一眼他的妈妈。
敬老院里面一个得了。
应该是得了老年痴呆吧。
这么一个老太。
没有上去。
他没有上去相认，也没有上去说话。
因为他妈妈可能年轻的时候对他也不好。
但是他呢。
远远的看了一下。
也算一个释怀。
也算一种原谅吧。
所以郑南也成为了天使。
因为他也影响了身边的人。
大家都得到了。
天使的爱。
这就是。
菊次郎的夏天。
我们说橘次郎的夏天啊。
虽然是一个真人的片子，但其实拍的也很梦幻。
也很梦境。
做的那些事情呢。
从表面上看是很荒诞的。所以有很多同学啊跟我说过，说菊次郎的夏天看起来很荒诞。
有时候呢确实也看不太懂。
这个确实是这样啊，因为。
我们说呃北野五拍的这个片子。
并不是拍给所有人看。
你如果啊。
你妈妈从小就对你很好，然后也没有离开过你。
你可能真的体会不到。
菊次郎。
的心情。
我们说这个片子从虚的角度来讲，我们可以说是前半段找妈妈。
后半段。
大家找天使。
寻找天使，甚至成为天使，成为彼此的天使，甚至成为自己的天使，对吧？因为。
你找妈妈不是为了找爱吗？
终极目标不就是为了找爱吗？
但世界上不光只有母爱呀。
还有天使的爱嘛，还有来自。
身边人的爱吗？
甚至来自自爱嘛。
我们说郑南自己变成了天使，不就是象征着他自爱了。
那北野我我们说菊次郎最后不也变得自爱了吗？
他从开始自暴自弃吧，他是个他是个他是个古惑仔呀，他是个不良大叔呀。
到后面他也开始斥责偷盗行为，对吧？他也改了呀。
他也开始爱自己了，是从虚的角度来讲，从实的角度来讲呢。
我们说。
菊次郎从外婆家出走，那最后肯定回到外婆家，对吧？外婆把你带大，外婆爱你。
外婆就是妈妈呀。
为什么一定要找亲妈呢？对吧？
然后从菊次郎的角度呢。
菊次郎的妈妈是谁呢？
菊次郎的妈妈其实是他老婆呀。
他对他老婆言听计计从呀。
而且他老婆很正的呀，很正义的呀。
价值观很正的，讲他做的事情都是很对的。他老婆。
帮助小男孩去找亲妈，对吧？打掩护，然后呢又去安慰那个外婆，然后呢又骂他。
骂她老公，让她老公学好。
如此强悍的强势的一个女人。
他就是你妈呀。
我们说缺乏母爱的。
缺乏母爱的菊次郎肯定要找一个这样的女人呀，对吧？缺乏父爱的女孩都很容易被大叔给给推了，对吧？那缺乏母爱的男人肯定被也会被强悍女生给推了嘛。
正常啊，所以说你看这个故事。
从大结构上。
其实跟。
绿野仙踪。
是一样的。
跟绿野仙踪是一样。
那我们就来。
咱们的命题作文了，好不好？
我们可不可以按照这种结构？
写一个自己的故事呢。
或者是说就练习一个自己的故事呢。
我们说这两个故事，你看。
从大结构上。
差不多啊。
对不对？
那我们就。
命题一个这样的作文。
好不好？
这个命题作文。
我们每个同学。
都要写。
我们当做全班的一次练习，好吧。
首先。
确定一个主角。
这个主角可以以你们最喜欢写的呃自己。
为原形。
好吧。
先写。
你自己。
或者你自己的一个变种。
你们明白我的意思，对吧？你的一个变形。然后第一件事情是什么现状？
这还能看见吗？
现状啊，你看陶罗斯的现状不可接受。
正男的现状不可接受，你的现状也不可接受。
从你的生活想啊，你的现状也不可接受，不需要什么后妈虐待你抽你，你看人家也都没有搞得那么激烈啊，不需要每一件事情都那么剧烈。
你就爱咋写咋写。
你的现状反正你的现状现在不太接受。
你对现状不满意。
对吧对现状不好不可接受。然后呢，在现状不可接受的情况下，哎。
想吃兵来雹子了。
激励世界。
基利世界。
或者是说得到一个远方的召唤，你正好觉得家里呆不住。
你得到一个远方的召唤。
得到一个远方的召唤，然后上路上路第一件事情，痛打看门狗。
然后。
开始找你的伙伴。
诶，怎么写了两个半？
找你的伙伴。
找到伙伴之后。
经历在终点之前，经历一系列你开心的事情，你爱咋写咋写。我们说你看他。
跟这个这个对手战斗，你在这里啊，当然也可以设对手啊，你可以设一个明确的对手。
谁在追你？比如说像人家这里如果是个女巫，这个女巫其实就是起一个追的作用。
对吧或者是说叫。
huntinging的作用吧，对吧？
就当撵你嘛。
那么。
在这个橘次郎里面呢，没有没有具体的行情，但是呢因为它是现实之路，它会遭遇各种各样的事情。你在这里呢你可以你可以考虑有一个贯穿始终的对手。
你也可以考虑。
把它拆解开。
一路不消停，对吧？
有各种各样的阻碍。
然后终点位置找到你的。
你要去找的那个人，但是呢。
不行不够不对。
重新调整。
调整目标也好，调整赌注也好，重新找。
然后最后。
实现真正的。
你的愿望。
按照这个结构。
写一个命题作。
我提几点刚性要求。
第一。
主角现状激励召唤。
他门狗伙伴。
终点。
全都不能少。
路程前半段。
你爱咋写咋写，这些奇幻的旅程，你路上的遭遇，你爱咋写咋。
我不拦着你。
多离谱都可以，就是写你生活中想干那些没有干过的事儿。
你看啊。
我们说。
绿野仙踪是梦境吧。
所以梦里面你。
全是陶乐斯想看到的那些事情。
看到小儿国。
看到一望无尽的花。
看到那些他认为over the rainbow的地方应该有的那些东西，蓝色的小鸟在天上飞，对吧？所有的梦想都能实现。
地上长出棉花糖，那不就是他的梦吗？
那你以为这不是吗？
你以为橘色郎的夏天不是他们的梦吗？他们前半段来干的这些事儿。
对吧摘荷叶抓青蛙，对吧？游泳、住酒店赢钱。
也是梦想。
电影就是梦想。
所以我给大家打的这几个点，你给我卡死了。
但是也不影响你发挥。
整个中前段。
你假想你离家出走，你踏上征程，你走向远方，你所能经历的那些事儿。
那些让你开心，让你梦寐以生以求的事儿，你都给我写上。
然后写到终点的位置，记住。
给我打住。
调整。
调整目标。
虚假的胜利，虚假失败，加大赌注，重新上路，然后去偿还。
偿还前面惹下的祸也好。
偿还前面走过的路也好。
重新翻转。
然后再提最后一个要求。
这个要求在这堂。
课的作业里面，在这个命题作文里面。
必须给我做到。
叫。
其实都是我。
把这个题给我点出来。
就其实都是我。
啥叫其实都是我。
我们再来看再来回看。
这两个例子。
劳勒斯。
在他的路路程路程上啊，遇到了三个伙伴。
稻草人儿。
铁皮仁。
和狮子。
你说这三个人是谁？
这三个人显然都是陶乐思呀。
他是陶乐斯的三个短板。
因为陶乐斯。
在现状在农场里面惹祸的时候。
家里人骂过他的呀。
妈，你这个人这么缺心眼，你这个人啊就胆小，你这人啊就是你你没有爱心。
他被家里人骂过这三个缺点。
所以他在梦境中梦境中踏上征途，遇到的想要找到大脑的稻草人，想要找到新的铁皮人，想想要找到勇气的狮子，实际都是他自己呀。
他是自己面对所有的问题一路走下来的。
他只是在路上获得了大脑，获得了善良，获得了勇气。
实际都是你你回头看看，你一路上就是自己走过来的。
只不过这是你的梦境。
你害怕你给自己创造了三个伙伴。
这才是绿野仙踪。
本身想讲的。
故事的意义。
当然了，这是个预言。
这就很好解释。
对吧。
我们来看菊次郎。
菊次郎和郑南一老一少。
两个人都没有妈妈。
你不觉得他们俩。
其实也是一个人。
我们说这个片子啊讲述的是郑南的故事。
表面上看主角其实就应该是郑南呀，因为主郑南在推动故事。
但它为什么叫菊次郎的夏天呢？
菊次郎是别鹦鹉呀。
而且很多人。
在第一次看片子没仔细看的时候，都以为那个小男孩就叫菊次郎呀。
所以才会有个疑问，到底谁是局次了？
对吧。
其实谁是菊次郎？
我觉得他们俩都是橘次郎。
橘次王就是一个找妈妈的人呀。
举鱼次郎就是一个找妈妈。
菊次郎代表所有被妈妈抛弃的小孩。
他既是那个大叔，也是那个小男孩。
他们俩就是在找妈妈。
所以他们俩。
也是二合一呀。
你有没有想过？
这个小男孩儿。
他离家出走。
他踏上了。
去远方找他妈妈的路。
怎么会有一个莫名其妙的大叔来帮他呢？
人家图啥呀，人家干啥？
那是不是？
那个大叔代表了勇气。
因为那个大叔一无是处啊。
那个大叔其实不是个好人啊，那个大叔行为没有逻辑，那个大叔可坏了，做各种坏事。其实单看那个大叔那个大叔其实挺不是人的。
是吧。
他他他他他给别人带来很多生命危险。
他做事很过分的。
但是他就是拥有。
我们正担没有的东西。
他有强健的体魄。
然后他有。
勇敢。
所以。
我们的菊次郎。
是真是存在的吗？
他不就是我们。
小男孩的一个分身嘛。
我们反过来说。
如果主角就是菊次郎。
就是被烟舞呢。
那小男孩又是谁呢？
小男孩不就是你小时候吗？
北野五小时候。
就是中年大叔菊次郎。
在小时候和妈妈分开了。
他怨恨他的妈妈。
同时他也想他的妈妈。
他当然会怨恨他妈妈这么多年没有陪他，没有管他，没有爱他。
但是其实在他内心里，他也在想。
是不是我小时候没有去争取一次呢？
没有去找他一次呢。
我如果当时去找我妈妈了。
结局会不会不一样呢？
所以从菊次郎的角度来看这个问题。
菊次郎是不是带上了自己小时候的一个影子？
去找自己的妈妈。
所以菊次郎才会。
在这个时刻。
去敬老院看了一眼他的吗。
但是也并没有相认。
他只是了却了心中的一个结。
当年。
去找或者没找。
又能怎样呢？
又能改变什么呢？
没有必要。
不需要别人来爱。
要自爱。
所以如果从局策郎的角度。
那正南。
真的去了吗？
是不是你自己去的呢？
你带着你小时候的执念去的呢。
所以说。
菊次郎和郑南。
也可以喝。
也可以叫做。
菊次郎的夏天。
没毛病。
你看这就是寓言故事，是明是明着来的。
我这几个人啊。
三个伙伴加一个主角是一个名账，对吧？这个没有以。
但是写实的片子呢。
咋说都行。
咋理解都行。
但是这根线。
这根筋儿是在的。
是存在合二为一的可能性的。
这个就是我们今天命题作文的。
最后一个要求。
也是难点所在。
我希望你们也给我写一个这样的故事。因为前面啊这些啊基本套路很简单的。
很简单的，包括这一段和这一段，你就去发挥你的想象力。
你想经历什么你就经历，然后最后再给我合题，再给我把你惹的事儿再给我全部再兜回来。
对吧但是结局我需要一个。
其实都是我的结局。
就所有的角色其实都是我都是主角。
比如说你看啊。
我们先给你顺一个吧，比如说你看啊主角就是你。
你们最爱写吧。
啊，主角就是我，然后我的现状呢就是哎呀学校老师也不待见我，对吧？啊家里我爸妈也不理解我，哎呀，我的现状不可接受，我我我我孤独，我冷我难啊，学校还有人霸凌我是吧？啊，我就不开心。
然后呢。
然后他们都瞧不上我啊，我功课也不好，对吧？然后呢就没人理我。
我们说。
这就是你比如说然后这就是你的现状啊，不可接受，确实不太舒适啊不可接受。
然后一个激励。
基地就是来自远方的召唤啊。
在咱们绝大多数同学啊不太可能去找妈妈。
对吧也不太可能去找大法师。
找远方的谁呢？
我们见网友吧。
而，我们见个网友。
对吧你看啊。
咱们收拾一下。
你这个故事啊就没有想法的同学，可以顺着我这个写啊，来你的现状我们说。
你先描述一下对吧？你先描述一下你的主角，然后再描述一下你的现状。
现状肯定是往下走，不可接受，好吧，然后得到一个召唤。
得到一个召唤，就现状往下走，召唤往上走，这个召唤的是诱人的。
这样你才能上路呀，对吧？现状往下走，召唤往上走，你才能上路呀。
我们说你看啊咱们大部分人啊。
没有远方的妈妈，也没有什么远方的大法师。但是我们有什么呢？
我们有很多网友。
我们现在的人啊，你看啊你很你有很多。
这个这个。
群。
对吧然后那个各种社交软件。
你肯定有。
某一个人你觉得哎，这个人虽然没见过，但是啊我觉得他不错，对吧？
我们有一个远方的网友。
比如说。
这个召唤你去见一个网友。
有有网友。
那再增强一下动力啊。
见网友为什么那么迫切呢？
女网友。
是吧美女网友。
美女。
而且呢。
对你有意思。
对你有有有示好，好吧，就这个美女对你你有示好，那你的现状就要更low，你在学校需要。
就没人屌你。
对吧你在学校没人屌你。
所以你看啊。
你上路去找这个美女，解决你这个现状问题，那肯定是去找。
小爱情嘛。
对吧当然你可以更具象啊。
把爱情更具象。比如说你想去破除。
啊，这个不就更明确了吗？
对吧。
因为这个美女对你表达了一些。
这个这个这个意思了，对吧？你只要能来是吧？来，你看那么就你不就上路了吗？
你不就上路了吗？
上路来。
看门狗。
自己找好吧，自己找看门狗是学校的小流氓也好，还是那个那个那个。
你们学校的某个老师对吧？一直欺负你的某个教导主任，对吧？你临走之前。
给他把车胎闸了之类的对吧？打掉看门狗，因为为什么要打掉看门狗啊，是要表示你上路的决心和没有退路。
这很重要的啊。
不是说非要真的揍个人啊，痛打看门狗，不是一定要非要揍个人。你看他陶勒斯神这里也没有痛打这个对呃，痛打那个那个那个那个那个女巫呀。
他是不小心把那个女巫压死的呀。
他也不是故意的嘛。
所以通达看门狗啊，不是说你一定要主动攻击某个人。
是斩断你的退路，是斩断你回到现状的退路呀。所以说你如果准备。
逃学离家出走，到远方去见网友了，你把你班主任的自行车带给扎了，而且还被他看到了，然后赶紧跑掉了，这就是痛打看门狗。为什么呢？因为你的现状你回不来。
明白这个意思吧？所以通打开门口自己设计一下，好吧，然后上路。
我们说上路接下来是什么？
是伙伴，对吧？
来，我们说伙伴，你设计一下呀。
伙伴我们说一般是你缺失的呀。
你是一个。
在学校里不受待见。
调皮捣弹的差生。
那你的伙伴就可以设计成一个。
在学校，哎呀。
人见人爱。
还当什么班长。
在优秀生。
乖乖女。
对吧是一个优优优质女孩，优秀生吧，优秀生。
优久生。
我们说你看。
然后你们就上路。
上路了，在这里就上路了，然后你就经历一切你想经历的事儿。
你觉得离开家之后，你能遭遇什么快乐的事儿，惊险的事儿，害怕的事儿。
离奇的事儿，恐惧的事儿。
帮助别人的事儿，别人帮助你的事儿，你往上怼吧。
就大家给我怼上。
对吧带着你的伙伴，带着你的这个伙伴，这个在学校里呃看不上你欺负你呃。
他为什么上路，你自己想着。
他为什么被迫上路跟你共同一个目标，你自己想着。
对吧你写一个人物关系所也可以写一个共同的行动目标行目标源，就目的地是一样的。比如说你俩都想去西双版纳，他有他的事儿，你有你的事儿，你俩都想去三亚，对吧？呃，你去见网友，他人家有别的事儿，但你再见网友，你还不好意思被他知道多丢人呢，对吧？
来上路。
一路上经历的事儿，你自己去写。
来终点，我们说终点位置。
中点位置这个中点线。
找到网友，这肯定要找肯定要见面了，对吧？在这跟我网友见面，但是呢目标不对，重新调整。
嗯。
目标不对。
重新调整。
就肯定办不成。
你出点事了。
那肯定办不成这个事儿。，那这个网友必须是那就有可能就是男的比如。
是男的对吧？网友是个男的。
那接下来会发生什么反转偿还的事情呢？
你在之前的路程当中啊，已经跟这个女孩啊从矛盾啊变得已经。
和解了，甚至产生一些友情了。
或者友情至上了。
对吧就是开始觉得哎，这女孩其实挺好的。
然后呢。
但是呢毕竟你是奔着破那个办大事来的嘛。
结果发现是男的之后呢。
那你回去可能回去又。
觉得还是他好，但是呢人家看上他了。
是吧。
人家这个女孩看上这个男孩了。
然后呢，你就跟这个你本来的网友，这个男的要竞争。
你的。
女孩，所以我们说反转之后偿还嘛，你在整个终点之后就来偿还你之前。
做的事情。
第一。
你跟这个你本来水火不容的优秀生女孩，在学校里完全两个世界的这个女孩产生了感情。现在人家他俩不管是愿意也好，还是被他弄走了也好，对吧？还是被他骗走了也好，你得解决这个问题，你得把他安件带回去。
然后呢，用什么呢？就用你前半段在路上学到的技能。
学到的。
智慧。
善良。
勇气。
去解决你心产生的。
这个危机。
然后。
最后。
我们说结局是什么呢？
结局是。
其实都是我。
这个故事咋咋其实都是我呢？
这故事就挺简单的，其实都是我。
优秀那么优秀的女孩在学校里是个乖乖女，学习又好又当班长。
人家干嘛要离家出。
人家干嘛要跟你一块儿离家出走？
你不觉得之前他说的那个理由有点扯吗？
真这个女孩真的存在吗？
他为什么一切都是跟你相反的？
你又高又壮，他又瘦又小。
泥又粗又黑，人家又白又嫩。
你学习差，人家学习好。
你胆子大，他胆子小。
你是男的，他是女的。
你爱吃肉，他爱吃菜，为什么？
他不就是你吗？
他是因为你你在学校混的这么差，你觉得自己孤独，你觉得没人理你，你生别人的气。其实你最生气的是你自己。
你最看不上的是你自己，你老觉得别人看不上你，最看不上你自己的其实是你自己。
你成天凶巴巴的不跟别人交朋友。
你是。
在自我保护，你是在自我嫌弃。
你何尝不想成为一个？
班干部。
每个人都喜欢的人呢。
所以这个女孩儿。
这个。
各方面都优秀。
爸爸妈妈很疼爱他，你没有爸爸妈妈，人家爸爸妈妈很疼爱他呀。
这样一个优秀的女孩。
就是你的梦想。
我们说你看这两个电影都是梦的呀。
我们说他们本质上都是梦，电影就是梦呀。
这么优秀的女孩，她不就是你的梦吗？
你不就梦想成为这样的人吗？
根本不存在呀。
你有没有想过你们之前你们俩上路那么优秀的女孩，哎，你们俩钱不多，然后去开房的时候开了一间房。
你有没有想过人家这个女孩真的愿意跟你住一间房吗？虽然钱不够啊。
你有没有想过你们作为一两个中学生去开这间房的时候，那个宾馆的老板也没有说什么呢？
因为他只看到你。
因为自始至终只有你呀。
所以说叫其实都是我。
这个女孩不存在。
他只是你跟你自己的一种和解。
他只是你的一个分身，你的一个假想。
那么我往后走。
终点的时候。
你发现你朝思暮想，一直很喜欢的那个网友，是个男的。
你以前真的不知道吗？
你没发现他是男的吗？
你假想出来的那个。
完美的你。
为什么会喜欢他呢？
是谁喜欢他？
不还是你自己吗？
你早就知道他是男的呀。
而且你早就喜欢他呀。
所以你转嫁出来一个女性的你。
去喜欢他呀。
所以他会才会跟他走的呀。
结局是什么呢？
结局就是。
完美优秀的女孩。
跟你的男网友。
他们俩一起。
遇到了危险。
你冲上去拯救他们的时候。
你死掉了。
因为你不死，他俩不能在一起。
你死掉了一个你。
另外一个你。
面对自己。
正视自己。
追逐了自己真正的爱情。
因为你内心里面住着着的就是女孩。
你看这样的话。
这个结局就符合。
其实都是我。
我们说你的伙伴是你，对吧？
还可以再放大。
我们说其实都是我啊。
我说你你们你带着这个女孩上路之后。
你带着一个女孩上路之后。
你们俩在故事的中前部。
先是碰到了一个，因为你们俩是离家出走的，你们俩不想回家，但是有人想回家呀。
对吧从故事的对账的角度来讲，你们俩不想回家离家出走。
相当于逆逆行。
但是有人想回家回不了。
比如说你们路上。
遇到了一个。
得了。
老年痴呆的那种。
老爷爷迷路的老爷爷。
那你们俩咋办？
你们是不是要送人家回家呢？
你们要送人家回家。
然后你们在路上。
碰到被人欺负的。
女性。
你们是不是要挺身而出的去帮助呢？
你们在路上。
看到这。
水库旁边玩水，在池塘边玩水，掉进水里的。
小女孩。
你虽然不会游泳，你是不是要下去救呢？
对吧？
我们说整个前半段是完善你自己吗？获得你所缺失的。
呃，智慧、善良、勇气一类的嘛。
你不是就是要帮助这些人吗？
我们说当然也可以有人帮助你，永远是救赎与被救赎嘛。
当你们。
遭遇危险。
被人欺负被坏人欺负，对吧？
会被被黑店敲诈的时候。
是不是也可以有警察叔叔来帮助你们呢？
人民警察来帮助你们呢。
那我们可不可以这样？
再去合一次。
其实都是我。
你为什么离家出走来着？
是因为孤独。
为什么孤独啊？
是因为你一个人涨。
你一个人长。
你过不去内心这这个坎儿，你没有家人。
我们在故事中后段。
解一下这个题。
是因为你小时候啊。
在一场车祸里面。
失去了所有的家人。
这场车祸是你引起的。
你在后座捣乱。
不听话。
对吧？
然后闹。
你爸爸在前面开车呢。
回头教训你，让你好好的，但是你不听话。
结果导致出了车祸。
一家人都死了。
只有你活下来。
但是你也因为车祸啊。
冲击太大。
痛苦也太大。
这段记忆封存了。
不记得。
也就是正因为这种封闭这种封存。
导致你现在的孤僻孤独不合群。
所以在这个。
征途当中。
你在路上。
遇到的那个老爷爷。
那个失忆的老爷爷。
那个想回家的老爷爷。
就是当年。
跟你一起坐在后座的。
你爸爸着急开车要送去医院的。
生了病的。
你爷爷。
然后。
你们在路上。
遇到的那个。
被人欺负的。
女性。
你想去保护你虽然从来没有保护过别人，但是你在那一刻特别想去保护的那个。
就是你妈妈。
你一直带在身边的。
这个。
别人看不到的。
完美的这个小女孩。
就是你长大了以后的妹妹呀。
死在车祸里的妹妹呀。
你想去保护你的爷爷。
保护你的妈妈，保护你的妹妹。
只不过你没有机会了。
所以你才在深深的自责里面。
他们全都召唤出来。
至于那个。
在你遇到危险，在你带着你的假想的妹妹遇到危险的时候。
站出来保护你的帮助你的那个警察。
就是你最不敢面对的。
你的父亲呀。
你爸爸没有怪你。
父亲就是父亲，他还是会保护你。
即便在你的梦里面，我们说电影永远是个梦。
即便是在你的梦里面。
在你的梦幻之旅里面。
你的父亲还是保护你的。
他没有抛弃你。
所以说从这个角度。
我们是不是就可以把。
路上所有的人。
合在一起。
都是你的。
分身。
都是你对家人思念的。
当然啦，同学们。
我说的这是理念啊。
你不要把每个故事给我写成鬼故事啊。
我说的是理念，你们自己去体会，就像北野武的菊次郎和正南。
人家没有说一定是一个人。
明白这个意思吧？
人家也没有写成一个鬼故事，最后这个小男孩哎，透明的滑落不着了。
我没有必要。
我说的是理念。
你故事该怎么写怎么写？
我只是需要你从理念角度，从精神层面。
给我制造一个，其实都是我的。
可能性。
没有让你写鬼故事。
好吧。
很多种做法。
基于这条线路。
达到这个要求。
这就是。
这节课的。
命题作文。
每个同学。
必须写。
这次不跟你客气了。
我需要把你从舒适区拽出来。
因为。
老师的作用就是这个。
逼着你学习。
让你在学习区里。
带着。
不断的扩大你的舒适区。因为。
读写能力啊。
是任何人都可以把它训练成。
舒适的。
就读写这件事情啊，不管是读也好，写也好啊。
你现在不愿写，我告诉你，你的读也就有问题。
愿意读的人基本也愿意写。
所以很多同学啊我跟你说，我发现有很多同学啊买很多编剧类的书。
买了也不看。
你是大熊吗？你有哆啦A梦吗？就书放在家里都能记住啊。
你就是。
尝试进入学习区，你进不去了。
所以咱们今天这节课。
就是我带着大家。
一头给我扎进。
学习区从书适区里走出来。
写一个命题作文，每个同学必须写班委会检查。
好吧。
这节课就这样吧。
下购吧。
我。